this is an email from greg it's one
sentence usually emails are
stories they're long and they are
drawn out this is quick and to the point
greg
asks can you tell me dr d
how you feel about the cancel culture
how do i feel about the cancer culture
man here we go greg
here's what i think about the canceled
culture i think number one
i think this idea that we go dredging
through
minutes years decades of people's lives
trying to find the worst things they
have done the stupid things they have
said the
the times they fell down when getting on
a bike and we drag that stuff up to the
front we drag that up to the now
and we hold them accountable for things
they did when they were children
when they were younger when they were
immature
when society said here's a different
story here's a different narrative
i think that's dangerous i think that's
unfounded and i think that's
ridiculous quite honestly i
love the idea of education i've been a
teacher for 20 something years i love
the idea of
growing that's that's the whole reason i
do what i do i love mental health
i love being a part of counseling and
coaching sessions i love these
calls here because here's why i love the
idea of somebody
going down a road and somebody's showing
them hey that
hurts that's painful that is not
helpful and then giving people the
opportunity and the tools to go
oh man i'm so sorry let me help let me
move let me shift
because the one thing that is
sure to shove people's hearts and their
actual motives
and their ability to change who they are
way underground
is to let them know the moment you pop
your head above
ground i'm gonna cut it off the moment i
find you said something way long ago
i'm coming for you i want people in my
life to have scars i want them to have
said you know what i used to think this
joke was funny
for years i thought it was funny and
then somebody looked me in the eye and
said
this hurts this is painful this sucks
and if you say this again
dot dot dot and then give people the
opportunity to say i am
sorry never again never again but this
idea of one striking you're out and it's
one strike retroactively
i just think it's painful it's dangerous
it's a really scary movement for our
culture in general
it's not a grace-filled way of moving
forward that said
if you are an idiot if you've got things
in your past that you need to repent of
that you need to come out and say dude
i used to think these jokes were funny i
used to treat people like this
i used to fill in the blank
you've got to decide to be different
right
and my rule of thumb is man if if i say
something offensive if i say something
that i didn't mean to or i see something
that hurts somebody and they come let me
know hey listen
listen when the way you say this that's
man that hurts a whole swath of people
that's not cool
or your idea on how to deal with
whatever issue
that's actually not factually correct
it's the way to do it is like this
then i get to choose to grow or then i
get to choose to go to war
and my hope is that people will shift
their default setting and
choose growth instead but man if it is
cancel
if it is i can't wait to find something
about you so i can end you
i just i think that's a dangerous
trajectory for all of us
and it's not fundamentally helpful it
just
shoves all the nonsense nonsense
underground it just makes it all
i don't know it makes everybody go
silent makes everybody go dark and that
is not how you heal things you heal
things in the light
you heal things with openness you heal
things with vulnerability you hear heal
things with forgiveness and pardon
and so greg that's what i think about
cancer culture i'm not a fan of it i
think it's got dangerous trajectory
and it's a scary place to go um and it's
really forcing a lot of our
smartest most extraordinary minds and
thinkers to just keep their mouths shut
to just not say anything because it's
not worth the risk man it's not worth
the risk
and that's not helpful for anybody we
need more poets we need more songwriters
we need more thinkers we need more
scientists
more people questioning and asking hard
questions and being able to say things
and yes we were all stupid when we were
kids that's why we were that i mean
that's
that's why the society as as large has
said you know what
let's don't let uh 16 year olds buy
cigarettes because they don't make good
decisions
right that's why we don't let 18 year
olds buy guns
right or buy beer because they're 18
they don't make great decisions
we'll give them 150 000 to go to college
we do do that that's stupid but
we we we have as a society have said hey
you know what brains aren't totally
formed yet we do let
35 year olds and 40 year olds go to grad
school why because they're capable of
learning new things and changing the way
they see the world
and so let's give people the opportunity
to grow and learn and change their heart
and mind
so greg man you can tell i probably do a
whole show on cancel culture someday
but that's my thoughts on that